foreign
is with us in Rochester New York hi Lynn
how are you
great Dave how are you guys better than
we deserve what's up
okay well um when they said I was great
honestly we have a crisis and we need
your help solving
um my husband my father had a dab in
North Carolina and granted it's only 15
Birds give me 15 cents more an hour
but what we would save in taxes and
everything else would be astronomical
um we put our home on the market the
real estate agent said that we will get
we should get 169.9 for it hopefully
there will be a bidding more but he said
the Market's kind of soft so it might
not happen we found out that we have a
mean on the home from past medical debt
of 21
000 and we owe 120 000 on the home
so if our home goes from 169.9
after we pay the lien and pay the home
off we're like we're gonna net
seven to ten thousand
and my question to you is should we take
it off the market
and just
Hammer off the debt
and then go forth with North Carolina
what is the uh what is the history on
this twenty one thousand dollar medical
debt
I was in a car accident 10 years ago and
we fought back and forth with the
insurance
um to take care of it they never did
and then my husband I got ill with lupus
and wasn't able to work and my husband
Sole Provider so things got pushed off
to the side and that was one of them so
the moral of the story is uh that
ignoring things doesn't make them go
away
exactly
the 21 000 medical debt that they
finally sued you on and took a lien
against your house on but have never
gone to seed your wages and that that
lawsuit was how long ago
yeah how long ago
um how long ago
probably five years ago they are
garnishing his wages now
I bet they are
okay
when were you all planning on dealing
with this
well
to be honest because they were taking
its wages we're like okay because we're
paying it
we just assumed that naively I guess
that's even a word that what is your
what is your household income
and the move to North Carolina was
prompted by what what makes you want to
go down there
just
to North Carolina uh just we love the
area we love the people
and
just life in general we feel would be
better there because here in New York
the taxes are astronomical I need more
pain okay here's the thing if you sell
your house you get a fresh start and you
get rid of this mess that you haven't
dealt with and you get to move on with
your life
that's a beautiful thing okay the only
downside of that process is you probably
could negotiate this twenty one thousand
dollar debt uh you know you're probably
offer them five or ten thousand dollars
they probably take it as settlement in
full
you have the ability to borrow any money
no we don't
could you go to your credit union and
get five or ten thousand dollars
we might be able to uh
my husband's credit isn't the greatest
right now no kidding because of the the
debt right I know big surprise
okay so I I would ask your credit union
if there's any chance that they would
loan you five or ten thousand dollars
don't take the money if they approve the
loan though get that in writing and then
go to the lawyers uh that have the that
have done the lawsuit on the medical
debt and see if you can settle this for
a quarter or 50 cents on the dollar if
you can do that that'll get the lien
removed for less than twenty one
thousand and then that would put a
little more money in your pocket as you
sell the house
if you want to go that route you can if
you don't want to go that route just
sell your house at least you'll be rid
of the garnishment and you will have
gotten this from over the top of your
head but please for God's sakes learn
the lesson from it
the lesson is this stuff doesn't go away
unless you make it go away
it just gets worse it's like a splinter
under the skin
that's very true yeah ignoring it these
things have a high rate of Resurrection
they come back
over and over and over and over again
and so you have to push that stuff
through and I'm fussing at both you and
your husband for your own good because I
want you to prosper and you're not going
to prosper with that habit in blaze
so yes I'm selling your house uh yes I'm
gonna try to settle that debt for less
than the face of it is because it is a
10 year old medical debt and they
probably will take less on it
um but
maybe they won't now that they got a
garnishment and also but when you get to
North Carolina it may mean you have to
rent for a year or two yeah you don't
need money yeah you can't come in here
just buy your dream house in North
Carolina yeah right and uh but 15 cents
an hour raise with no income tax and no
garnishment
an hour raise and I feel like you've won
so um yeah you're going to come out
ahead that way so and you know you get a
fresh start and you kind of get you know
different different setting and
everything so I'm with you on the move
overall and that's what I would try to